hey everybody and welcome to live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're
going to make a grid layout material UI
is the framework that we're using the
style or react app and they have this
grid component built in so we're gonna
use that but we're gonna make it
possible for the user to switch between
views so the grid view will be one
possible view of several so we'll
probably just work on two views today
the grid view and then the main view
which will probably will be the default
we've already seen that so probably we
won't really need to work on it that
much but we will need to make sure that
we can switch back and forth so I
haven't decided yet with the best way to
do that is and by that I mean how are we
going to handle how that information is
passed between components in terms of
what the view should be so I'm gonna
start by telling you what I think the
the solution could be and then getting
feedback from you all and depending on
what feedback I get that'll determine
how we solve that problem so say just
today is Friday the 13th so I'm not
really superstitious at all but if you
are superstitious about that sort of
thing watch your back today
cuz it's Friday the 13th uh-huh all
right let me take the live chat real
quick to say hi
world says you look less tired today
okay that's cool I'll take that I'm
actually I was trying to think if I got
a sleep I don't even remember how much
sleep I got I was up earlier than normal
with kids but I think I got at least 7
hours so let's see I'm surprised I think
I actually looked really weird on this
camera because I got different lighting
coming from my screens depending on
whether I have a light screen or a dark
screen so it's always odd to see myself
like that oh okay all right let me let
me fill you in on what happened
yesterday so Sebastian asked about the
issue with the resource center that we
looked at at the end of the stream
yesterday so I had actually forgotten
about that until you brought it up so
and it looks like my mic is still
popping I wonder if maybe it's it's not
my phone
so the phone's far away the cords
farther away than it's ever been
hmm if it keeps popping if it keeps
popping and it gets really bad let me
know and I will just switch over to the
the built-in mic all right it's good now
okay yeah he said if it gets really bad
I'll just switch over I'm using an
external mic now but I could just use
the one that's built into the iMac and
the mic I got it wasn't really that
expensive so if it's if it's breaking
then I guess that's what I get from
buying a cheap mic okay so here's what
the problem was so we had correctly set
up the
max file size in the in our server Jas
file this was for the our last project
project 2 which was the Resource Center
we had set up a file upload form and we
used form Z was it forms e no no we use
form Z for client-side form validation
server side we used formidable SWE's
node formidable and we set our max file
size and we had it said it's something
very reasonable I can't remember exactly
what it was but it should have been able
to handle the amount of data that was
going in so I it occurred to me that oh
maybe nginx needs to be said and I
looked it up and it turns out the
default max upload size for nginx is one
megabyte so anytime someone was
exceeding that one megabyte either with
one file it was big or the total of all
files that were being uploaded then it
was failing not it wasn't even getting
you know to our server das file it was
failing at our nginx level which we were
using as a reverse proxy on that
digitalocean droplet so I just looked up
how to increase the the max upload size
so I increased the max upload size and
then I increase the the time out I
forget what it was called but basically
I increased the amount of time it would
allow something to be uploaded that
fixed the problem so that was it and I
think it was Sebastian was it you who
said it was probably the the upload size
so you were you're definitely right
about that I just was thinking that
somehow it was in our server J's file
that we had mess it up but we didn't
that was that was fun it was with nginx
and that was entirely on me because I
don't think I set up that server on the
stream so had I done so
one of you all will probably would have
thought of it but I didn't so we're
gonna have to keep that in mind for this
project because we will of will we have
a file upload I think we might I'll have
to double check on the other we're not
gonna work on it today so it doesn't
matter but I'll double check on the live
version of this project and see if we
have a file upload ok so let's see ok so
it wasn't you so somebody said something
about file upload so I don't remember
who it was but whoever it was you were
right see everybody are giving it to you
hey Gideon she's late today don't worry
you you weren't that late just a few
minutes ok oh ok awesome
fontsize is that better does that work
ok alright let's get started and I am
gonna remember to set my timer today so
I want to do kind of a shorter stream
today depends on how things go but it's
Friday and I want to go home and see my
family so so I don't want to stream for
a really long time because I wanted to
want to get out of here uh-huh
so we're gonna do at least one session
maybe two we'll see how it goes
ok so let's get started let me show you
what's going on right now I have done
some things so far depending on how much
time we have at the end I might review
the pull request but just be aware we've
I've merged two pool requests one from
Harshit one from Sebastian and both
awesome pool requests so you can review
those as pour quest six and seven we're
going to see some of the changes because
we're going to be working on the same
files that were changed
but I'm not gonna try to go home right
now but I will go over them later if we
have time
okay so here's kind of a demonstration
of using this grid component so hard
should actually put the grid component
in on his pull request so I modified it
slightly but that was part of his pull
requests you can see you can see the
other part as well so we now have a
responsive sidebar so it automatically
hives or shows depending on screen width
so that's awesome that's exactly the
behavior that we wanted from that
component so so thanks again for that
Harshit and it's actually those were the
those are the big parts of this pull
request so I guess we did review it at
least from this end of things
so basically when we have the grid view
we want things to stack up like this and
let me see we'd probably when the screen
got this big we probably want to go even
smaller but I just put some numbers in
there just to to demonstrate so we
dropped down to two columns that we drop
down to one and then when we go to our
our default view is going to look like
what we have here so this is what we
want our default view to look like and
then we've just seen the grid view so
those are the two views that we want we
want to be able to talk them with toggle
them from this button up here I can zoom
trying to zoom in here and it's not
working I don't know what's going on the
batteries are almost dead on my trackpad
there we go so I may have to change out
the batteries here in the middle of
stream but when we press this what we
want to happen is that icon will change
because the second click will take you
back to the default view so we'll have
two icons that change in and out
depending on what you click here then
obviously we want all of these cards
that have our posts to go to the new
layout based on the click so here's what
here's what I'm thinking about actually
I wrote this down so I wouldn't forget
um
so actually wrote it down on a piece of
paper with a real pen so really
old-school today haha so here's what we
need we need to be able to pass the the
value so I don't know we're gonna state
or something but we need the components
to be aware so we need obviously this
app bar component to be aware of what
the user selected for the view the view
type the the layout type we also need
this category J S component to be aware
of the layout type so what we need then
and then with this we go a couple of
ways so do we just have the state exist
in the app bar component and then pass
it down as a prop to our category J S
component because this app bar I believe
lives in our layout or layout component
so potentially the state could exist at
the layout component and be passed down
as a prop to our app bar and if you're
not familiar with react this is probably
really confusing I'm gonna describe this
now but then we're actually going to go
in and do the code and hopefully it'll
be less confusing for you so that's one
option right we just take the the parent
component of both of those and we have
the state there we
pass it down as props that's a
possibility the other possibility is do
we have our global or store basically so
I know we're not using Redux directly
now because we switched out for Apollo
which uses Redux behind the scenes
anyway so I guess what my question is is
if we wanted to have a global store that
would hold that value so that any of our
components could have access to it would
we be able to do that with Apollo or
would we need to bring react back into
the or redux I'm sorry Redux back into
the picture and use Redux for that or or
is that unnecessary now we will have we
will have some other views and
potentially we might have some other
data that should be in some sort of
global store so Redux if it has to be
Redux and we can't do it with Apollo
Redux may seem like overkill for this
one thing but I suspect we're going to
have some other pieces of data that
would be useful to having a global store
so I'll let you you all think about that
if you have any thoughts just put it in
the live chat for now we may as well
spend some time getting this grid layout
to look how we want it to look and
that'll give us all some time to think
about what we want to do I mean we can
always implement one solution and then
switch later if we need to but I was
actually I was gonna try to do it
earlier and then I thought no I want I
want advice from you all on this before
I before I actually implement it so
let's get to some code
let's see since we're gonna be working
on this first let's check this up now
here's the the thing that I'm not sure
about I did mess around with this a
little bit and I kept getting errors and
I decided to just remove what I was
doing and I figured we'll redo it on the
stream and it'll be easier for everyone
to follow so in our category J s let me
make some space here in our category J s
file right now you see some of the stuff
has changed but basically the the main
thing here is that we've imported this
grid component so first we have this
container this grid container if you
want to check out what's going on look
at the docs for material UI make sure
you go to the newest version the beta
version and then check on the under the
Layout tab you can see more about this
grid there's a lot of other options we
could do but for now we're using this
grid container and then for each of our
posts we're gonna have this grid item
right so each post each card will be
wrapped in this grid item and right now
we have it set on small screens to take
up 12 so this is a column thing much
like we used with the column classes in
materialized CSS very similar to that so
we have extra small is takes up 12 so
the full width then half width on small
and then a third on medium screens I'm
assuming large is LG so let's go with
large and we'll just pop put in four
right here so I think I want that anyway
let me put in the N grok link I forgot
to do that at the beginning so I already
started it up before the stream and
okay if you're not familiar with how we
do things I look at the live chat again
after our Pomodoro session is up so in
about 15 minutes I'll get to the live
chat so please don't think that I'm
ignoring you I will get to all the
comments and questions in the live chat
soon okay so since we've wrapped that
component let's I want to go ahead and
see what this looks like with four yeah
okay it's four obviously we don't have
enough posts to really see the four
columns but you can you can guess write
it there would be two more okay so
here's the the first thing that I need
to do we need to handle so if we're
going to keep it like this we need some
way to either change these values or
just make use a ternary right like an if
statement and render it this way or the
original way we were rendering it like
yesterday right how we render it on the
home page because here's what happens
let me move make large 12 so this is
what happens if we just try to change
the value to 12
it gets really big so we don't want that
so if there's some way I mean
realistically we could just set a max
width on the cars right I guess that's
an option
I'm assuming that this would just be
positioned in the middle we can let's
try that let's sit on Macs with I have
dev tools open on my other screen here
so I'm just gonna set a max width and
dev tools just to try it out go 500
pixels okay so it actually isn't it
doesn't get centered I'm not sure if we
could okay so we could potentially just
give it a max width of however many
pixels we want and then a margin:0 auto
and that that would work okay that's not
bad
that's actually not too bad my initial
idea was to just have basically
duplicate this take out the grid and
then render one of the other based on
the view but if all we have to do is add
or take away those two lines of CSS that
just may be the simplest approach that
would result in the least amount of code
so
let's do that
who
okay so I think that's settled
now let's see okay Omar says you could
do like the the column offset John
Hanson says you could flex justify items
okay and Sebastien says there is
something built in alright let's check
that out
I'd much rather work with what's built
into material UI rather than just use
some CSS to override I mean this in this
case the override is just like really
obvious and easy but still I think if we
can use what's built in the material I
we have less of a chance of like weird
things happening in our UI that are that
we haven't thought of you know on some
browser screen with device combination
we might have something weird happen we
won't know about it we're less likely to
have that happen if we don't try to
override things in material UI okay so
let's check it out then
where we had layouts grid
should we use the center then
okay Sebastian says the last one is demo
okay where we have things centered all
right let's see what it what it looks
like
all right so if we justify:center in a
line Center then so I guess this would
be basically what we need just a it's
just a five direction
okay let's try it out so is that again
okay so this is a container it's just
inside sorry that's probably really
small I'm I didn't even think about it
okay let's see I do want to set this is
I don't want these centered there we go
I didn't want them centered on the page
you remember we tried that on a previous
project and it was it seemed like a good
idea but then we actually look at it it
was really weird okay so we do just want
justified center okay
alright let's try it this should be
pretty simple I think if we just say
justify let's separate this out a bit
and it is Center right yet Center
okay
check it out now okay it looks like
we would probably still need a max-width
but it should be centered now so if we
give it the max width and it's not
yeah okay so what happened to great dude
you just fess in it
all right let's look back here and see
if we miss something
all right let's make sure we have
direction row as well
ro
all right I'm just gonna put the
max-width right on these because it's
getting annoying to do it every time
whoops style
all right
now that's weird
I guess I could put it on here
all right cool that works
let me go back actually not that did not
work I wanted it to work we need all
right let me check the live chat and see
if I'm missing something that you all
have seen
okay
Blake asks what's the material UI link
its material - UI calm all right let's
think maybe this isn't going to be the
the simplest way
all right let's see yeah so it's messing
up what we're doing here the max width
is but this max width has no effect
hmm
so let's get rid of this
I want to inspect this quickly and see
what's happening with that max with and
if it's being applied anywhere
all right so never grid and then within
that
okay I see all right we're a little bit
stuck right so I've just manually set
max with and dev tools and you'll see
the highlighted portion right now is the
the div that is from the grid component
and then this div that's highlighted now
is the card component so you could see
the the orangish part there is is the
margin so the grid I don't know if the
grids gonna be able to Center this the
way we wants so we might be better off
just doing a little bit of our own CSS
yes the Sebastian says the problem is
that the large 12 will use full width on
the large screen and that's it but if we
want it to be one column then we have to
use the 12
okay all right let's see
alright let's get rid of this for now
actually this might not be applying
because it's possible that we're not
passing the styles on to the dis
component to left to remember that now
so I guess I'll leave this in here for
now okay my timer is up let's do five
minutes a question answer and that'll
give us all a minute to think about this
as well really I probably should just do
something so that we can move on and we
can always change it if we want to later
on all right let me scroll up and stop
going through here
I see a lot of you also saying hi hey
hey everybody I see some some new people
in the live chat I haven't haven't seen
the names before so welcome thank you
for for joining us for the live stream
Nikhil says me maybe the sidebar could
be improved in terms of user interface
yeah I think it could it's it's still
work-in-progress now so I'm not I want
to get all of our options on the sidebar
first and then I'm gonna adjust it at
that point so this this is not going to
be it's um its final form so I
definitely agree with that okay
Sebastian says so earlier when I was
talking about whether or not we have a
global store or we just pass things down
as props to components from a parent
component Sebastian says if you have a
global store then yes include it there
if not you can use react state directly
and switch components based on the state
I think that's that's going to be the
simplest way to do it is just to keep
the state and the parent component and
pass it down to the child components and
if it gets more complex later on we
could always add Redux if we have to
xavier says what's your opinion on CSS
grids okay and rook asks for some
clarification saying do you mean the CSS
feature called grid or the thing
bootstrap and other CSX CSS frameworks
do let's see okay it doesn't look like
Xavier responded so Xavier I'm gonna
assume that I just answered both either
way so if we're talking about the grid
structure that's common among CSS
frameworks I think it's really easy to
work with
so despite my problems with this this
framework here I I like them I think it
makes it very easy to do responsive
layouts I haven't worked directly with
the the new CSS feature that is grid
that much at all I basically just kind
of read a little bit about it so
honestly I think any new feature of CSS
is a good thing right it you don't have
to use it so it's not it's not really
bad because you could just choose not to
use it but since it's there you have the
potential to use it on something so I'm
hopeful that it'll be very useful so I
just need to learn a little bit more
about it before I start using it
Blake's asks can you change the color of
the wave effect on the category buttons
probably oh yeah yeah I can definitely
change it it will change at some point
see
all right Nikhil says could something
like an image holder be used here like
when the website loves their these
frames slash image holders present then
the image loads that might speed up the
website a bit improve the UI yeah let me
think yeah we might might be able to do
that I'll probably wait till later on if
everything runs really fast then I
probably won't bother implementing
something like that but if we are
running into some performance issues
then that would be good to to have in
there what do they call it premature
optimization right so yeah but that'll
be good to put in if we need it later on
if we have time
okay I'm almost to the bottom of the
live chat so my timer went up but I'm
just going to answer these last few rook
ass is that dark github theme a standard
feature the white is kind of blinding
yeah it's not a standard feature it is a
I have this plug-in called tampermonkey
that lets me run scripts on certain
pages so I use that plug plug in with
another thing called github dark so with
those two things it gives me all these
options of various like a dark theme but
I could I could change it so I they have
pre-made themes but then also you could
customize it even further if you wanted
to
I never tried any of these other things
maybe I should try them one day anyway
so that's it
okay michael says hey Jesse I never
catch these live love the streams always
catch them later the same day oh well
I'm really glad that you could be here
live for this dream that's awesome
Nino says is this video for advice or
front end for advance front end it just
depends on what we're working on so
sometimes we work on more advanced
topics for front end occasionally we do
work back in and DevOps stuff mostly
front end though sometimes we go over
some basic front end stuff so it just
kind of depends on what we're working on
day to day for this
I don't know this stream falls maybe
somewhere in the middle I don't really
think it's that advanced but if you're
not familiar with react some of it might
be kind of confusing so hang in there
and ask you so many questions as you
want if anything is confusing let's see
alright last question and then we're
going back to the code in actually so in
is it pronounced in uh or or ina
let me know I don't want to I don't want
to mess it up
all right let me start the timer
first is correct
inna okay awesome yeah if I ever
pronounce any of your names incorrectly
call me out on it let me know I I want
to get them right okay so I guess we're
doing two Pomodoro sessions I know I
said I was gonna do one but now that I'm
into it I want to get something done
here okay I just saw it Anna kills
comment here about the logo and the
adjacent top RSS okay watch this said
where's my there we go here it is okay
um yeah actually you know what I was
looking at this earlier today and I kind
of thought the same thing what do you
all think is it okay that these are
different sizes or would it look a lot
better if let's say this line lined up
with with the bottom of the app bar so
we'd either make the logo smaller or the
app bar bigger I like the size for the
logo I'm a little hesitant to make make
it smaller I think it could be slightly
smaller so maybe it needs to be a
compromise where we meet right about
here I'm a big fan of a slim taut nav
but in this case this does look a little
weird let me know what you'll think
potentially though it might not look
quite as weird if we take out this line
we'll see I want to know what you all
think and then maybe we could try some
several different options not on today's
stream but on another stream we'll try
it out okay so let's get this thing done
here because I spent a whole Pomodoro
session just trying to get this lined up
in the middle okay I see there's a lot
of stuff coming up in the live chat now
just want to let you know for those who
are just joining us I will get to all
your questions in the live chat as soon
as this Pomodoro session is over so I
just started one so we have in 23
minutes I'm going to go back to the live
chat I'm gonna answer everything so if
you can't stick around to hear the
answer live you can hear the answer
later on when this the recording of the
stream is available on the free code
camp YouTube channel all right let's do
this
so here's what I'm gonna do for now just
so that we can get something that works
and worried about how we're gonna handle
state because that was that's really the
big issue that I'm more concerned about
this is this issue is like we know how
to make it work we're just trying to
figure out the best way to do it
so for now
Center all right we can get rid of this
right because we didn't hoops not all of
that we can get rid of these I don't
think we were actually we actually need
that also we can get rid of this oh no
you know what I think I want to keep
that yeah let's keep that here and then
yeah and then we'll give it a margin of
zero Otto all right so that's how we'll
settle it the zero means top and bottom
margin is 0 and then Auto means it just
automatically fills in the left right
margin equally but now we need to
actually pass these in to that component
so let's check out our post preview
component which I don't have it up right
now so let's go back to hear those
preview ok so let's see all right we
actually we have styles here class name
let's see if that's enough to do it I
don't remember how I've done this in the
past
oops styles not too fine up
awesome that did it okay let me explain
what I did in case you're not familiar
with react so in our category ojs file
we had put this style these styles right
and think of this as just inline CSS
it's really a JavaScript object but
that's how how we do it in react so
initially it didn't work because this
component it wasn't really rendering
anything to the Dom right it was it was
rendering this component this post
preview component and then on this
component what really ends up getting
rendered is you know this card which in
itself is a whole other component so
there's a lot of layers to it but
basically what we needed to do was pass
it the style so we're passing the Styles
down from parent to child component and
at first it didn't work because with
this component instead of having to type
this props style we bring everything in
here and then we don't have to type this
props so really useful to do it that way
just in terms of in this case it
wouldn't been a big deal but if you have
to type the same prop over and over
again or a lot of props you can save a
lot of a lot of characters by doing it
like this okay so that's what we did so
now what we have then we can go so you
can see it still works so we should be
able to keep let's just let's try this
actually this might have just simplified
things a lot for us so if we go back to
three with this one great
all right so what this means is we
actually only need to change one thing
in this component we can leave these
styles here that's not a problem all we
have to do is change this value we'll
probably want to change it across the
board yeah we'll probably want to change
it across the board to twelve but now we
don't have to worry about changing any
styles all right so let's do this now
we're gonna go all the way up to our
parent component for all of this so if
you see our layout so this is where
we're actually rendering this component
so this is the category component and
this is a stateless functional component
but then we also have this render
categories okay and that's a child
component of of category right but we
also wrapping this in layouts layout is
where we bring in our app bar as well so
let's see
actually it might be a little bit more
complicated than I thought so
so lay out
I'm trying to think of whether or not
the state should live in layout or it
should it live in cat category I would
rather have it live in layout because I
want this these views to persist across
you know the home view and category
views and whatever other thing we have
so we will have some other things let's
see
okay
okay so here's the thing how if we make
the state live and lay out is there even
any way for me to pass something from
lay out to you know any of these
components
see
I don't know it is kind of looking like
maybe we should have a global store my
thing is is this basically if we have
the state live here in Category then
we're going to have the state living in
two different places so we're going to
have it here in Category and then we're
also going to have it in you know the
regular home view so we're gonna have to
have it at home you as well let's see
yeah
so we're now gonna have consistency
across state we don't want two different
states we're not really going to be able
to keep them in sync
I mean I guess we could but we're gonna
be repeating a lot of a lot of markup so
I mean I was just thinking like let's
say that we had we had this state exist
at each of our views all right which is
repetitive and then we had some sort of
on click that got passed up up to the
parent component right so we had like
what the on click handler would live in
the parent component and get passed down
as a prop right but we'd have to have
that same one and every parent component
every one of our views so that's not
good all right I could clone elements as
Photoshop
okay so hard should just posted some
stuff some code in the live chat so
let's see saying react clone element
this props children logged in this state
look
all right so so you're saying that here
we could pass props to the children if
if that's the case that's actually
exactly what we need
all right let's try it out so let me go
I'm gonna copy this and paste it in here
for now let's see layout type and for
now I'll just say grid I have a C okay
it didn't like that you didn't like this
react
let me see I just looked up on my other
screen one of my other screens how to
pass props with this props children or
state
okay I see need this
we're calling element Davis frosty
we might need to map over this react
all right let's see
okay
Ishod this okay so from the example that
i just saw and stackoverflow they were
we're mapping through and and then
cloning the element so it said that you
have to clone it because of the I guess
the the children are immutable so you
can't directly do anything and I guess
that's not working either I don't think
it likes you
us using react inside there so if we
pull this out let's put it up here
and each other
okay
let's try like that
I don't know doesn't want us to put
anything in here what is the problem
most
that's really weird get rid of this
that's so weird what why is it not upset
about this but it was upset before
okay child is not defined no I'm fine
9:36
equals
hmm
I don't know maybe I wonder how old this
is saw that oh hello okay harsh it
is uh submitting a pull request bulletin
me eggs okay not yet are you working on
a pull request for that then let me
check my time two minutes okay
all right so for now
I
let's try this now
the
okay Savior says you you wouldn't have
that this problem with CSS grids well
it's not it's not the layout anymore
that's the problem it's it's trying to
pass the state I can't believe I'm
saying this now but redux would probably
make this simpler this because Redux was
so hard for me to grasp it was so
complex but they're they're probably and
I just I know how I would do this in
redux
alright let's just get rid of this and
go back to how it was where it worked
and
all right
okay so here's what I'm gonna do
it's Friday I'm not gonna work on this
anymore we're gonna come back on Monday
now if if anybody wants to submit a pull
request to try to fix this
that's wonderful if not I think on
Monday unless I come up with another
idea I think on Monday I'm just going to
bring redux back in or figure out a way
to access the global store that Apollo
is using and add to it and I'm just
gonna have this in here because this is
a perfect candidate for something that
should be in a global store it's
something that needs to be accessed by
multiple components and it's gonna have
to be passed you know down several
components so you know that's that's one
of the big benefits of Redux is when you
have something like that you don't have
to keep passing you know things back and
forth between you know several levels of
components so that's the plan right now
at this point I'm gonna go to the live
chat I'm gonna check out all the
comments and questions answer as many as
I can and then then I'm gonna finish up
so that I can get out of here and enjoy
the weekend although tomorrow I'm
probably just gonna code all day so it's
not like I'll be doing that much
different but I'll get to code all day
from a recliner in my basement so much
more comfortable okay I'm gonna go back
up to where I left off let's let me
commit this the that way you all can see
everything oops oh you know what I have
my my terminal my other screen all right
let's bring this in
get status
all right so we've changed our press
preview in a category yep that's what
exactly we wanted to change let's see
what did we do
oops
okay all right so everything should be
up now on github and okay now let me go
to the live chat
okay Blake s could you send the link for
github styles yeah let me find it
you have dark
I'm pretty sure this is it I'm gonna
paste it in in here and if you're
watching this later and can't see the
live chat if you just search github dark
github dark theme for me it was the very
first thing that came up it's a github
repo okay John Henson says CSS greed is
less code it has a fair learning curve
though it's a game changer it is a must
learn as it will work on all new
browsers very soon
I'm gonna have to take the time to learn
it here sometime soon Xavier says I
agree CSS grids are much easier to work
with and many grid systems and the most
common frameworks cool ok anna says I
enjoy your stream awesome I'm glad that
you enjoy it see and it says your
English is great I would hope it would
be great since I'm I had to take English
class every year of my life for the
first I don't know since I started
school and up until I was 18 I guess
Nina says how long have you been coding
I started learning how to code when I
was a teenager but it was just really
basic stuff so I don't even think I'll
count that I did a little bit in college
with C++ but I didn't really start to
code until maybe like five years ago and
I would say like really seriously doing
JavaScript coding or attempting to do
JavaScript coding for about three years
now before that the two years before
that I did some but a lot of what I did
was basic team LCS
WordPress theme customization which
which is fine and you know I made money
doing that and a lot of people make
money doing that but you don't really
need to use a lot of like more in-depth
you know coding with that so so I'd say
more realistic measurement is like three
years of full-time like dedicated work
with coding mainly JavaScript dead
zombie says I just want to say how
grateful I am for your tutorials I
recently started working as a junior
front-end dev and watching you helps me
so much
Oh awesome well congratulations on the
job really happy for you and I'm really
glad that I could help so awesome I mean
that's like exactly why I initially
wanted to do this dream is to help out
to help out and just show people
especially people who were newer just
what it's like for what for what I do
and see
okay in Ashe do you have a mentor sadly
I don't really have a mentor I had kind
of a mentor so I had a friend and he was
actually younger than me but I'd known
him since I don't know probably my early
teenage years and I was good friends
with his older brother and he's the
reason that I started actually doing
coding for a living I didn't have a job
at the time and I had two kids and a
wife and I really needed to get a job at
make some money and he brought me on
with his he had like a media marketing
company and he brought me on and
basically I did work for him but he paid
me to learn you know it was an hourly
job and he would say take a couple hours
I'll pay you for it and learn how to do
this thing or that thing and then he'd
give me work based on that so that was
really awesome he taught me a lot about
contracts and and clients about search
engine optimization and different things
like that so in terms of like JavaScript
coding not necessarily a mentor in that
but in just a lot of other things that
that happened he was a mentor to me also
a really good friend so that's the kind
of the closest I've had to a mentor but
it'd be cool I mean I've gotten advice
from people who have been doing this for
a lot longer than me or who are a higher
level skill wise than me I wouldn't
really say mentorship just you know
advice here and there
Wow so dead zombie says one guy who's
been working for three plus years as a
front-end dev has been assigned to me
cool so assigned as your mentor just to
clarify so I understand that's really
cool to be like I said I don't I haven't
really had a mentor in terms of coding
specifically with with JavaScript but
from everything I've read about
mentorship and how important it is like
it can be a huge help
jamjam Euler sorry for mispronouncing
that so Jam Euler says do you have any
course on Android development sorry for
asking something awkward oh no don't
don't be sorry at all that's that's
definitely not not awkward feel free to
ask anything
I don't currently have any courses on
Android development and I don't think
like me personally I don't have it I
don't think that free code can't does
but I'm not a hundred percent sure if
they do it would probably be some sort
of video series or potentially like I
don't know blog posts about it in the
free code camp medium publication so I
don't know I would maybe check the
playlist on this YouTube channel to see
if there's something I am working right
now on learning react native which can
be used for android development so I
really hope to be using some react
native stuff on a stream at some point
potentially we might turn this project
or another one of our projects that
we've already done into an Android app
in an iOS app with react native so if
you can't find something you know right
now you know hopefully within the next
I don't know month or two maybe I could
I could squeeze it in so I don't
actually have any official projects or
directives from my boss to do an app but
I think we could work it in to spend a
little bit of time here and they're
working on it I think that would be nice
that would be the kind of thing that I
could just kind of surprise my boss with
and say hey I've been messing around
with this check it out and I think he
would be happy with it
at that point when he saw it then he
would probably say okay keep working on
this and then we could we could do more
with it
oh so you all heard the vibration when
someone was calling on my phone yeah I
normally don't answer during the stream
unless I think it's really important I
think that was just a spam caller though
I wouldn't have answered it anyway even
if I wasn't streaming
okay lucky says it's asking about what
the theme is in Visual Studio so yeah
Blake said this is Adam so yeah this is
Adam and not Visual Studio sometimes I
do use Visual Studio but I'm not for
this project
the theme is SETI so SETI is the theme
oh wait a second all right so hard
should just pasted some new stuff in
okay Murphy or seven
hold on a second that's he was going on
all right let's check this out quickly
okay so this ended up working cool I'll
merge this in a second I'm just going to
copy and paste it real quick just so
that I can show on the stream that it
works
actually let me alright let's just merge
this right now we'll merge there quit
like okay so I know I said yesterday
normally you'd want to test it out but
literally one line has changed right I
could see what line that is so we're
safe to to merge this in all right now
let's pull it in isn't good amazing he
just said live collaboration right here
on the stream with code being pulled in
so that's really cool thanks hardship
for the code let's check it out NoHo
what is this she like this for you kind
of from the files define it that's
ridiculous let me reach there at the
server because I that shouldn't have
anything to do with what we're doing
Oh after I just said now I feel silly
cuz I just said oh we don't have to
worry about it it's just one line what
is how you all saw it
you you saw the you the code right this
was it
we a clone element this cross your
intestine what all right I'm just going
back to the live chat right now
all right love you finish in the live
chat alright so for now
let me just revert yeah let's revert
this I just want to make sure that it
was this and not something else
weirdness happening okay so alright so I
have to merge this now right yeah
all right our common history is gonna be
a little messy
all right so let's double check make
sure okay yeah it definitely was
something all right so anyway we'll
figure this out after the stream well
not really I figured out on Monday let
me finish with the live chat okay okay
in ass do you have any trouble with
deadlines no not really
the deadlines here are not always like
strict deadlines so I don't really have
a problem so I should say like in terms
of the initial deadlines for projects I
don't always meet the initial ones but
that's because the scope of the project
usually changes at some point and
because it changes then we change the
the launch date accordingly because it's
just not realistic anymore
also I'm usually waiting on other people
for approval for different things so a
lot of times I have everything done
before it it actually needs to launch
but then because I have to wait on more
information or different things it
doesn't launch on time I mean in that
case you know what can I do
it's I'm waiting on people that are my
superiors to get back to me with the
okay that we can launch this so
generally though I do launch things on
time so it hasn't been an issue there's
never been a time where you know I've
been reprimanded for not making a
deadline usually it's been the opposite
and and people have been pleasantly
surprised at how quickly I can get
things done so not all the time but a
lot of times so luckily is that I'm
getting a lot better at correctly
estimating how long things will take
it's taken me a long time to get to that
point when I can estimate correctly but
I would say if you're giving an estimate
of how long something should take always
over s
to make things complications always
arise in projects so very rarely where
everything go perfectly according to
plan so factor that into your time if if
you need to give time estimates you know
definitely definitely give yourself some
allowance for that unexpected element
that always seems to happen all right
Blake says I have my portfolio running
off a github repo with pages running but
I want to run it off of the username
repo what is the best way to do it
okay it looks like rook already answered
and says basically create a repo with
your your username github io as the name
and enable pages okay cool
I didn't realize you could do that so
thanks thanks rope for that answer
Harshit says what plans about the server
how will you protect the wordpress api
it still returns to four or three yeah
it does still return a four or three I'm
not sure if that's something to do with
the plug-in so probably when we get
closer to the time when this will
actually launch I'll worry more about it
if it's still we're turning the 403 but
until that time I'm just going to
continue to upgrade the plug-in when new
upgrades come out and because I think
they're aware of the problem I do need
to double check in the slack Channel but
I'm pretty sure someone's already
reported the issue it might be reported
on github as well so I think it's being
worked on and this project the WP graph
QL plug-in project seems to be pretty
active there's always activity on the
slack Channel at least every day so I'm
that it probably should be fixed I would
think before we're ready to launch in
terms of the server we do need to figure
something out about WordPress so I don't
know if if you've realized this or not
yet but potentially right if we want
this to be a login only site so we don't
want anybody to be able to see this
except users who can log in that's fine
but what if somebody knows how to use
the WordPress API or graph QL and
decides they're going to try to pull
data from our WordPress installation now
normally that would be a very kind of
remote possibility right because we
could certainly not advertise the URL at
all we can make if some crazy long URL
that no one would ever guess try to hide
it like that but potentially someone
could still get it there's still a
chance so it's it's not enough to just
have our react portion of this password
protected we have to have some way to
protect it from the WordPress end so
that's something we're going to have to
think
about I think we have multiple options
on how to do that so we will get to that
at some point I'm still not hundred
percent sure how I want to do it though
so if anyone has any ideas about that
let me know we'll talk about it in an
upcoming stream or like I said I do have
some ideas I just kind of need to test
them out and see if they'll work with
with the graph QL plugin that we're
using world says what's the advantage of
using material UI instead of some other
framework like flex box or bootstrap for
material UI they have react components
built in so that's a huge advantage if
you're using reacts otherwise so some
frameworks rely on jQuery to do some
things and or or not or potentially
vanilla JavaScript but either way you're
not really supposed to manipulate the
Dom through other means all Dom
manipulations should be done the react
way within your components otherwise it
messes up Reax ability to have an
accurate picture of the state of the Dom
at all times so it's better to use a
framework that is made for react and
works within those constraints then you
use another one it's not impossible
though if you check out project one we
used a just a regular non react
framework materialized CSS that's very
similar to bootstrap and we made it work
with react it worked I mean the site's
functional it's been live for a couple
of months now
we've had no problems with it so it's
just better to do everything right the
react way Oh her shirt says tell me I
will work on it this weekend I'm not
sure at what point what I was talking
about when you made that comment so
harsh it let me know what what in
particular were you saying that you
would work on I mean there's definitely
definitely love to work on still and if
you're willing to work on it this
weekend that would be amazing
Eric's Eric asks how hard is it to learn
react from using angularjs let's see I I
don't know that I'm the best to answer
this because I knew it allure before I
started using react but I was not an
experienced angular developer you know
by by any means at all I just kind of
messed around with it on side projects
and wasn't very successful so if you
know angular I don't think it'd be that
hard for you to figure out react but
they are different so you won't be able
to just come straight over and say okay
this in angular equals this thing and
react exactly right so it's a little bit
different mindset but if someone has the
skills to be able to learn angular I
have no doubt that they also have the
skills to be able to learn react so I
wouldn't worry too much about it if you
were trying to make the switch but I
would say like just be open to thinking
about things differently with react than
you did with angular so like don't think
there's going to be like I said those
exact correspondence to the way you do
things are
things work so but I don't think someone
who knows angular would have any issues
and learning react let's see so you sick
I'm not sure I pronounce this Sokka sick
soch I si si so anyway says hello from
Russia thanks for your streams hey
welcome and how's it going in Russia
thank thanks for saying that you're
welcome I'm glad that you're you're
watching the stream and that you joined
us here in the live chat
oh cool okay Anna says thank you for
your stream have a good day and weekend
oh you welcome thanks for watching being
a live chat and you have a great weekend
as well oh okay okay so hard she was
talking about the plugin yeah so
syndication
okay so hard [ __ ] is commenting a little
bit about this authentication and our WP
graph he'll plug in so hard [ __ ] says my
idea is to screw up the plug-in and
write our custom graph QL query this way
we will use authentication on the server
like like a loss 2.0 plug-in okay
I'm open I'm open to it
Xavier asked Jesse what is it you want
to try to do with your grid layout I
kind of want to give it a shot with CSS
grids over the weekend okay so basically
I want to I guess I can show you on this
other site let's see this will probably
the easiest way to just show you
okay so here's the current bulletin this
is the default view right which looks
pretty much like the default view we
have now and then when you click on this
icon for grid view it goes like this
and then you can go back to what I'm
calling list view and of course it's
responsive so even if you were in good
view and you went down to mobile size it
would only take up one you know one
column so as you get smaller you have
less columns so that's that's basically
what I'm trying to accomplish that we
can click a button and have the view
switch
all right awesome
okay JV or says challenge accepted how
hi cool
that's it I'm at the bottom of the live
chat so it's after 4:00 p.m. on a Friday
almost time for me to get out of here
so thank you so much for watching for
joining the live chat for helping me
thanks for the pool requests this was a
really nice stream I liked it we didn't
get that much done but we talked about a
lot of issues that we're gonna face in
the future and we have some ideas so I
like that we're on a good track here and
some new people today in the live chat
so that's always awesome I enjoy meeting
you virtually here so I'll be back
Monday and until then have a great
weekend